invitée landon d'antenne 2010 je vous le
disais au début de cette édition patrick
font et philippe val avant de discuter
avec eux parce qu'il chante aussi
nous allons écouter l'une de leur
dernière chanson qui s'intitule émigrés
émigrés texte et musique de philippe val
et puis nous discuterons avec tout à
l'heure à propos de leur dernier
spectacle au théâtre du gymnase marie
bell
l'émigré d'émigrés reste là t'en vas pas
à nantes est installé rien chez toi chez
moi
après avoir donné au tarif minimum ta
sueur est ta santé on te dit mon
bonhomme désolé voyez-vous n'a plus de
place mais nous voilà de la monnaie pour
prendre ton billet n'écoute pas le
croûton qui les y est son a6 avant de
prendre son vol vacances courtes unis
émigré reste la tombe à ba1 tente et
installé
bienvenue chez toi
chez moi
je n'y tiens toi bien soit mort à l'est
soit bon et est ce que tout ça tient
devant l'humiliation ceux qui insultent
c'est le même genre de français qui
trouvait les nazis sympathique et poli
par force d'avoir le nez collé au figaro
ils ont dû attraper lampions hausse
oh
des vies mais reste là on va pas
les installer
rien que chez droit chez moi
il y a quand même en france plus de gens
que tu penses toutes les couleurs n'ont
jamais pu faire peur de dire si tu
quittes le pays
on peut craindre le pire tristesse quel
ennui
si on se mélange plus je crois qu'on est
foutu la pauvreté sera aussi gai
tu nous laisses tomber on va doucement
sombrer
dans la vielle aure idps fruits confits
et on te laisse parti dont il va se
tarir
dans les sables mouvants
séguin
vivre et reste la roja
cette année
c'est pas chez moi
cela va pas
je fais toi
il vous est toujours aussi mis quand on
écoute bien votre chanson va pas passer
c'est pas lui dans tisme s'il me
semblait que c'était des choses un petit
peu évidente qui fait qu'il fallait dire
comme ça sur le ton de la chanson sur le
ton de la bonne humeur malgré tout il
fallait le dire
enfin je sentais ce à quoi je vais aussi
c'est qu'ils vous aiment sont ceux qui
appartiennent à votre génération celle
de 68 un petit peu c'était un peu
l'esprit charlie hebdo qui a disparu
mais vous y subsister toujours oui mais
il n'ya pas que des gens de notre âge
surtout au gymnase là il ya des gens
âgés qui viennent il ya beaucoup de
lycéens et universitaires qui font le
gros du public maintenant qu'ils sont
plus jeunes que nous maintenant aller
patrick forestier justement il n'ya pas
des personnes qui viennent vous voir
sans savoir exactement qui vous être
parce que des fois on est attiré par les
noms par le succès est plus facile et
plus étonné si parce qu'on est en face
du rex alors au lieu de voir blanche
neige ils viennent nous voir
ce qui fait qu'on se retrouve avec des
gosses dans la salle et des soixante
huitards pouvoir blanche-neige s'amusant
comme tous les gosses vous vous
connaissez bien puisque vous vous
occupez de jeunes dans votre quartier
vous faire l'éducation non seulement
dans la ville mais aussi dans qu'est ce
que vous faites très exactement avec ses
enfants une école de spectacle qui
existe depuis six ans qui s'appelait au
début écoles parallèle et puis j'ai pas
aimé ça écoles parallèle parce que
l'école pareil c'est parallèle à l'école
donc ça revient au même et c'est une
école de spectacle c'est géant
j'apprends le spectacle aux enfants on a
monté une troupe et puis on tourne
professionnellement un petit peu dans
toute la france enfin même beaucoup
d'ailleurs et on joue des spectacles on
change tous les ans c'est destinés à
leur apprendre le métier du spectacle
à mon avis un des plus beaux métiers du
monde est ce que certains de ces enfants
sont devenus des noms connus dont le
spectateur non non non non à partie lors
aussi mais il nous a quittés et nous
sont encore trop jeunes là la doyenne à
20 ans est la plus jeune a 15 ans
philippe val c'est une vieille
complicité avec patrick font depuis bien
longtemps
oui puisqu'on a commencé à travailler
ensemble dans les années 70 on s'est
rencontré à peu près en 70 et au théâtre
de dix heures
on fait beaucoup de choses de file alors
justement là on a entendu une chanson
dont vous êtes l'auteur et le
compositeur mais vous vous partagez un
petit peu la tâche semble utile
c'est-à-dire qu'on écrit toujours
séparément
parce que l'écriture c'est un travail de
solitaire met en scène on improvise des
choses des sketches qui finissent par
devenir établi complètement mais sa part
d'improvisation à deux c'est assez rare
qu'on écrive à deux c'est assez rare et
dans vos spectacles quand on va vous
voir on se rend compte qu'il ya une
bonne part d'improvisation aussi ou en
tout cas où il fait très bien oui si
tous les soirs il se passe quelque chose
d'un petit peu différent bien sûr bien
patrick font vous vous avez de temps en
temps une action solitaire c'est à dire
que vous n'êtes pas tout je sais pas
toujours font et val vous faites vos
propres spectacles à ses délires qu'en
dehors de fonte et valley à philippe
valletoux seul qui fait ses spectacles
et puis moi avec la compagnie du chat
l'ex ça s'appelle comme ça avec les
jeunes et où on fait du théâtre ça
permet de passants qui se tait dans un
système dans une recette en une espèce
de carrière à tout prix je dire ça
permet de se reposer la tête de faire
autre chose et aussi de temps en temps
de prendre des vacances parce qu'on en a
besoin
oui je crois que vous avez aussi écrit
des textes pour thierry le luron qui je
ne pense pas un partage toujours visiter
ah bah non mais ça ça fait déjà assez
longtemps ça cela dit thierry le luron
j'ai connu quand il débutait au cabaret
à l'échelle de jacob en 69 et il y avait
personne pour lui faire des textes à
l'époque moi j'étais dans le même
programme je lui en ai fait est bon
c'est vrai qu'on partage pas souvent les
mêmes idées et puis d'ailleurs le land
et ça veut pas dire qu'ils prenaient
tout ce qu'ils avaient dans les textes
dans les foyers des petits coups de
stylo de temps en temps expérience qui
les intéressait oui ça m'intéressait
parce que j'ai fait six mois télévision
et six mois télévision tous les
dimanches avec les problèmes de censure
qui avait à l'époque ya encore
d'ailleurs maintenant mais moins la
preuve c'est qu'on est là mais avec les
problèmes qu'on a qu'on a rencontrés que
j'ai rencontrés pendant six mois puisque
je faisais les textes de thierry faisait
des sketches et cetera
c'est en 73 j'ai ri j'ai frôlé la
dépression nerveuse j'avais des brames
qui les bras qui me tombait parce qu'on
on est vraiment tombé sur des
producteurs une connerie monumentale et
je suis bien contente de dire
aujourd'hui concerne l'information en
tête de chou je suis pas là pour
m'identifier à ma maison
les poèmes de sanction nous n'en
connaissons pas oui l'homme un peu moins
sur notre est-ce que ce n'est pas trop
difficile de prendre la succession de
guy bedos était un des gymnases lui il a
fait un véritable tabac la cdu race
derrière une succession parce que dit le
dos c'est quelqu'un qui a un immense
talent et puis qui a fait un gros succès
mais c'est agréable aussi de passer
derrière bruges et guy bedos
il ya patrick chan et philippe valent
donc au théâtre du gymnase marie bell ça
se trouve à paris et 7 depuis quelques
jours jusqu'à quand jusqu'où peuvent
février jusqu'au 20 février
eh bien nous prenons date maintenant
nous savons un autre rendez vous c'est
celui que nous donne jean leber tous les
jours avec metal m